The third preliminary topic is system design, and that is considering the system
as a whole, possibly with respect to the environment in which it's going to run.
First item is architecture.
Okay? We've already talked about nonfunctional requirements and
their effect on architectural style.
Second is how you're going to deal with concurrency and
there's a spectrum of possibilities here between having everything in a,
in a single process to having one thread per object.
Physical design has to do with how you're going to allocate tasks to
processors and deal with any peripheral advi-,
devices that are part of the system.
If your application has a,
a significant data storage requirement you have
to make some decision about whether you're going to use a database to do that.
Whether you're going to do files.
And how you're going to deal with issues like lock, locking.
And protocols talking back and forth to the data repository and the system.
What is going to be the overall control regime of your application?
Okay.
Is your application going to be reactive, such,
such as would be the case with, when you have a GUI and
the user is controlling things with mouse clicks and, and key presses?
Or is your application going to be proactive, that is, it has its own
it has its own control in mind Whereby it
calls the appropriate subcomponents in order to accomplish whatever its goal is.
And finally, an important thing to consider is how you're going to handle
errors and failures of various sorts.
Okay?
Is there a recovery technique you have in mind?
Are there error reporting approaches you're going to take with the user?
How are you going to deal with that overall problem?